En este video vamos a presentar la idea de la
carga formal, y como veremos es una herramienta
que podemos usar como químicos para analizar
moléculas; no es la carga de la molécula entera,
en realidad es un número que podemos calcular
para cada uno de los átomos individuales en una
molécula. Y como veremos en futuros videos, nos
ayudará a pensar qué estructuras de resonancia,
qué configuraciones de una molécula contribuirán
más a un híbrido de resonancia. Así que antes de
profundizar en eso, vamos a dar una definición
de carga formal y luego, como práctica,
vamos a calcular la carga formal de los átomos
en cada una de estas estructuras de resonancia
para el ácido nitroso, ambos son estructuras
de Lewis legítimas, ambas son estructuras de
resonancia legítimas para el ácido nitroso,
pero pensaremos en cuál contribuye más al
híbrido de resonancia basándonos en la carga
formal. Para la definición de carga formal,
y vamos a hacer esto para cada átomo en nuestra
molécula, vamos a calcular el número de electrones
de valencia en un átomo neutrón libre y a eso le
vamos a restar el número de electrones de valencia
asignados al átomo enlazado. Y la siguiente
pregunta es: ¿qué significa ser asignado? Bueno,
desglosaré esta definición un poco. Si queremos
pensar en los electrones de valencia que se
asignan a un átomo enlazado, éstos van a ser el
número de pares de electrones solitarios más la
mitad del número de electrones compartidos. Así
que intentemos darle sentido a esto aplicando esta
definición de carga formal en los componentes del
ácido nitroso. Comencemos con este hidrógeno por
aquí. ¿Cuál es el número de electrones de valencia
en un átomo de hidrógeno neutro libre? Bueno,
hemos visto esto varias veces, podrías verlo en
la tabla periódica de los elementos. El hidrógeno
neutro libre tiene 1 electrón de valencia. Ahora,
¿cuántos electrones de valencia se asignaron al
átomo enlazado? Bueno, una forma de pensar en esto
es dibujar un círculo alrededor de ese átomo en
la molécula para capturar todos los pares de
electrones solitarios. Podemos pensar en eso
como la mitad del enlace. Podríamos decir que para
cada enlace tenemos un electrón porque es la mitad
de los electrones compartidos, cada enlace tiene
2 electrones compartidos, pero tomamos la mitad
de esos y no tenemos pares solitarios por aquí.
Entonces, el número de electrones de valencia
asignados al átomo enlazado, en el caso de este
hidrógeno, es 1, así que estamos tratando con una
carga formal de 0 para este hidrógeno. ¿Y qué pasa
con este oxígeno de aquí? Bueno, hacemos el mismo
ejercicio. Me gusta dibujar un pequeño círculo
a su alrededor. Y así el número de electrones de
valencia en un átomo neutro libre de oxígeno, que
hemos visto varias veces, es 6. Y luego a eso le
vamos a restar el número de electrones de valencia
asignados al átomo enlazado, el átomo enlazado
tiene 2 electrones solitarios, y luego obtiene
la mitad de los electrones compartidos, de modo
que la mitad de los electrones compartidos sería
uno de este enlace, uno de este enlace y otro de
este enlace; los sumamos todos: 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 - 5
= 1 positivo. Y, entonces, la carga formal en este
átomo de oxígeno, en esta configuración del ácido
nitroso, es 1 positivo. ¿Y qué hay del nitrógeno?
Bueno, haremos un ejercicio similar. Un hidrógeno
neutro libre tiene 5 electrones de valencia,
lo hemos visto varias veces, y puedes verlo en
la tabla periódica de los elementos. Y luego a
eso le vamos a restar la cantidad de electrones de
valencia asignados al nitrógeno enlazado, vemos:
1, 2, 3, y luego un par de electrones solitarios,
así que son 5, y entonces tienes una carga formal
de 0 aquí. Y luego vemos este último oxígeno.
Este último oxígeno, un oxígeno neutro libre,
tiene 6 electrones de valencia, de esos
vamos a restar el número de electrones
de valencia asignados al átomo enlazado: 2, 4, 6
electrones solitarios más la mitad de este enlace,
así que eso es 7 electrones de valencia asignados:
6 - 7 = 1 negativo. Así que este oxígeno tiene una
carga formal de 1 negativo. Y quiero recordar que
no estamos hablando de la carga de la molécula
completa, la carga formal es realmente una
herramienta matemática que utilizamos para
analizar esta configuración. Pero una forma de
conceptualizarlo es que en esta configuración
este oxígeno en promedio tiene un electrón
más alrededor, un electrón de valencia más
a su alrededor de lo que tendría un oxígeno
neutro libre. Este oxígeno tiene un electrón
de valencia menos alrededor de lo que tendría
un oxígeno neutro libre. Ahora veamos esta
configuración aquí abajo. Bueno, este hidrógeno
es idéntico a este hidrógeno, no tiene pares de
electrones solitarios y sólo tiene un enlace
covalente a un oxígeno. Entonces haríamos el
mismo análisis para obtener que su carga formal
es 0. Pero ahora pensemos en este oxígeno aquí.
Un oxígeno neutro libre tiene 6 electrones de
valencia, la cantidad de electrones de valencia
asignados a este es 2, 4, 5 y 6, entonces 6 - 6 es
0, no hay carga formal. Y vamos a este nitrógeno.
El nitrógeno libre tiene 5 electrones de valencia,
este nitrógeno tiene 2, 3, 4, 5 electrones de
valencia asignados a él, así que menos 5 tiene
0 de carga formal. Y luego, por último, pero no
menos importante, este oxígeno de aquí. Un oxígeno
neutro libre tiene 6 electrones de valencia,
este tiene 2, 4, 5, 6 electrones de valencia
asignados al átomo enlazado, así que menos
6 es igual a 0. Lo que vemos es que esta primera
configuración, o podríamos decir que esta primera
estructura de resonancia del ácido nitroso, tenía
algo de carga formal, tenía +1 en este oxígeno y
-1 en este oxígeno, mientras que el de aquí abajo
no tenía carga formal, todo tenía una carga formal
de 0. Y como veremos en futuros videos, mientras
más cerca de 0 están las cargas formales de los
átomos individuales será más probable que
esa estructura de resonancia contribuya más
al híbrido de resonancia. Pero hablaremos más
sobre eso en futuros videos. El objetivo de este
es sólo para sentirnos cómodos calculando la carga
formal de los átomos individuales en una molécula.